[Musique]
la liberté
l'unique fenêtre vers le monde extérieur
pour Manolo Georgina et manuel s'ils
accueillent régulièrement des visiteurs
il ne peuvent en aucun cas franchir le
seuil
la police
les Rodrigues le rêve sont à Sherbrooke
depuis 2018 à leur arrivée au pays il
aurait impossible d'obtenir un statut de
réfugiés mais ils obtiennent un permis
de travail au fil des années ils
occupent plusieurs emplois s'intègrent à
la communauté mais l'an dernier tous
s'écroule il reçoivent un avis
d'expulsion pas question de retourner au
Mexique où il craigne pour leur vie
avait une cafétéria elle raconte que les
cartel aurait brûlé son commerce alors
qu'il la croyait à l'intérieur parce
qu'elle aurait refusé de les laisser
vendre de la drogue dans son restaurant
notre vie court un danger dit-elle l'an
dernier apparaît date la famille ne voit
qu'une dernière option se réfugier dans
cette église en évoquant le droit au
sanctuaire un principe qui n'a aucune
assise légale mais qui dans les faits
est respecté par les autorités jamais il
n'aurait cru y passer une année complète
moi
c'est très difficile particulièrement
pour mon fils confie-t-elle il me
demande chaque jour quand pourrons-nous
sortir tout ce que je peux lui dire
c'est prions
avant de rentrer ici Manolo allait à
l'école maintenant ce sont ces
enseignants qui viennent à lui
aujourd'hui ces cours d'anglais
qu'est-ce qui te manque le plus
sortir avec mes services
mais sortir vient avec un grand risque
celui d'être renvoyé au Mexique leur
avocat c'était white is vinsky souhaite
que le gouvernement fasse preuve de
clémence
était assez forte
mérite la chance que quelqu'un regarde
leur demande avant de se faire dépoter
le moment est venu dire Georgina pour
notre santé mentale notre décision est
prise nous sommes prêts à sortir de
l'église et à courir ce risque
la famille j'espère que le ministre de
l'Immigration seanfraiser leur accorde
la résidence permanente pour motif
humanitaire je peux pas leur donner
aucune garantie il le savent à Ottawa la
député libérale de Sherbrooke assure
faire tout ce qu'elle peut pour les
aider elle interpellé le ministre
fraiseux à plusieurs reprises
les minutes passent le jour présent est
pareil à celui d'hier tout comme celui
de demain ils sont une douzaine à venir
ici sur une base régulière des repas
comme celui-là le pasteur Samuel Vauvert
donne secours en a partagé des dizaines
avec les Rodrigues Flores ça c'est une
expérience humaine qui n'a pas de prix
et qui me marquera pour le reste de ma
vie la famille rêve d'entamer un nouveau
chapitre Georgina s'imagine ouvrir un
restaurant mexicain à Sherbrooke mais
d'ici là elle n'a qu'une seule souhait
la liberté la liberté le cadeau d'une
vie pour Noël
[Musique]